I have here pipe of sorts i blowing here
and a current comes out through this
spout just so that you are convinced the
air is coming out watch the air is
coming out okay now I'm going to put
this very light ball just above the
spout okay
and blow on it the upward streaming is
supporting the weight of the ball so
that it's in deflation is floating in in
the middle of the air so far so good but
now
I can support it completely off the
vertical let's see if I can do it in the
other direction too
did you see that well it's of the
vertical the ball is spinning
this phenomenon has to do with all sorts
of questions whole range of questions
that are often discussed in popular
literature and the technical literature
and has to do with for example how a
plane flies now the usual explanation is
that its newest theorem that's the
technical term that people always invoke
and it's supposed to say that if you
have a flow of fluid water what have you
the sum of density times velocity
squared over two so speed squared plus
the pressure is supposed to be constant
so if there's a large speed there's
small pressure and if there's a large
pressure this small speed and they'll
say they'll have you believe that well
there's fast air flow on this side and
there's slow air flow and decided so the
fast side has a low pressure and this
low side has a high pressure so the high
pressure region is pushing the low
pressure region and so it's going to be
lifted in this direction fighting the
gravitation of all and they will say
that that's the same thing why the
airplane is flying now this is not quite
right because there is film if you read
the actual proof and the statement and
so on says that for each streamline that
is the flow line of a fluid particle
that's true but you cannot apply it
automatically to different stream lines
and in this case there is a stream line
coming above the ball and then stream
line below the ball but these are
different stream lines you can't apply
there no it both at the same time you
can't say well this stream line in this
stream line they have the same kind of
constant no it's it's not the implied in
the theorem there is another version of
it which is called a time-dependent
Bernoulli for potential flow which means
that if there is no vortex in the system
you can apply learn week to the entire
fluid region but in this case there's a
lot of vortex you saw the whole thing
spinning so you cannot apply the new
either either
so it's actually a nonce application you
can't use ville-marie to explain this so
what is happening is the question what
is really happening has to do with
something that is subtle but in some
sense even more primitive than the
renewal you see when we do this is
streaming above the ball and it's being
deflected along the ball like this why
does it deflect because the air has to
stick to the ball and in a fluid is a
continuum
it doesn't want to so the snot snap out
and create a vacuum so if there is a
solid boundary for example or some body
like this he wants to go along the
boundary of this thing and that's why it
gets deflected and underneath it kind of
goes like that also so the long and
short of it is that the whole airflow
comes in like this but goes out like
this so it curved but whenever the
trajectory of a moving object curves for
example fluid curves there must be a
force that's curving it yeah and that
force is being supplied by the ball
because ball is leading the fluid around
this because the fluid wants to cohere
that's the technical term and wants to
go around the ball well action and
reaction if Nature has produced an one
effect it has to pay for it by having
the counter effect and the reaction is
from the fluid the surrounding fluid air
to the ball and if the ball has supplied
this kind of force in order to deflect
the airflow the air has to supply the
counter force in order to lift the ball
so whenever there is a curvature of the
flow line that creates what we call the
pressure gradient if it's curving like
this the inner part has high pressure
and outer part has low pressure and
mathematically speaking it's really
related with
Hugo force-sensitive for speed V is like
V squared over R R is this or the radius
of this curvature and that's actually
the pressure gradient that you are
creating so the again long and short
with either because you have a high
pressure region low pressure region it's
going to be lifted upward
the bull is providing this deflecting a
curving trajectory so the ambient fluid
has to apply a force which compensates
for that which is in this direction and
this is really an effect of a curving
trajectory of any kind so if you have a
curving trajectory for example the
radius of this curvature is r and it's
going at the speed V and it's going
around it turns out that there is a
centrifugal force which is like this and
that's a Rho is the density and this is
the pressure gradient which increases as
you go from in to out that's what the
lemon sized Bowl yes turned the air
around the corner like it make it made
the complete air change direction yes so
the air gets its revenge in a way if
you're gonna do that then I'm gonna push
you in the opposite direction
that's a but for the air to get its
revenge it has to touch the ball like so
where is the air punching the ball is it
from underneath or yes because it's not
polar cannot because I hasn't got like
Nokes or anything that can pull with
well it can pull because you see the if
you have an X suitable and air leaves
the ball well if you can just freely
leave the ball it's going to leave a
back vacuum behind but the fact the
matter is the fluid next to a solid it
doesn't want to create a vacuum it
doesn't want a cavity once to sort of go
here you wants to fill the whole space
with some substance so when it's pulling
away by that very effect it's actually
pulling the solid as well and on the
molecular level it's clear what's
happening you know molecules are all
attracting each other all the air
molecules are kind of collected by
spring to the neighboring region and
when you pull the spring that spring you
know shrinks and then pull the whole
thing in and similarly if you push this
spring get compressed and that's what
the pressure is
a mathematician and a physicist when
you're sitting on a plane flying to
Japan and you look out the window and
you see the wing you know in your head
are you imagining the wing being pulled
up by the air or pushed up by the air
well I think it's both you see the wind
is so designed that roughly speaking the
air comes in like air comes in like this
and goes out like that so it's current
is the trajectory is deflected and that
creates two effects both which are
conspiring of course that the air
underneath is pushing upward and the air
above it's pooling that's a figurative
way of speaking but essentially again
what's going on is that pressure there
is a pressure difference and you have an
effect from high pressure region low
pressure region you are pushing against
each other by the way pressure is
everyone knows its force divided by area
if you multiply top and bottom numerator
and denominator by length you get Force
Times then that's called work that's a
form of energy and area times length
that's volume so it's actually energy
per volume the pressure is like
potential energy per volume and we are
saying that if you have a high pressure
region that's high potential energy
region and low potential energy region
which is low put a low pressure region
then the stuff moves is pushed from high
pressure to low pressure which is
exactly the same thing as if you have a
say a slope like this hill and a valley
where all the balls wants to roll from
high potential region to the low
potential region just rolls down and
gain some kinetic energy by doing this
so the pressure is acting like a
potential energy let's let's do the
spoon actually so let's go yeah let's do
the spoon because I like your language
of the taking revenge
that's great that's wonderful so you can
do another home extender to see that
whenever a fluid flow curves the
trajectory of the fluid curves it
creates a pressure gradient difference
in pressure which sucks
something in on one side and pushes
something out on the other side as soon
as the spoon touches the water the water
gets deflected you see from a straight
vertical down to the side and that has
the effect of pulling the spoon in you
see the poof and that's because if the
water momentum is changed from this to
this that means that somebody must be
providing the force from left to right
and the counter force is applied to the
spoon from right to left and that sucks
in the spoon from this side and if I
touch this spoon
the water would escape from this side
it's the opposite effect
[Music]
yeah and that's essentially like that
you know they've datum Bowl but the
picture is seen sideways you see the
airflow who is coming in like this and
going up like this and if you turn it by
90 degrees it's exactly the same picture
yeah and this is the ball which is
sucked in the direction opposite to the
direction of deviation of the fluid flow
and the challenge is to just tuck the
ball up and put it in a cup now that's
of course very very difficult to do so
you shouldn't do this in public and
because the chances of success are very
small